in the last video I constructed a
scenario where we get all of the upside
in an investment and our downside was
limited to essentially 15% of our
investment or in that case was 25 50 I
think I made a slight math there I kept
saying 24 50 it was really 25 15 I also
apologize I realized I had my sound
settings a little off but hopefully
you'll be able to still listen to that
last video but just to review what we
did is we took instead of putting thirty
dollars let's say the asset price was
thirty dollars instead of just going out
there and paying $30 for it what we did
is we put 25 50 aside and then we used
for 50 to participate in Geithner's
project or his plan and we put in for 50
the Treasury puts in for 50 then the Fed
lends us $51 and then we're able to buy
$60 worth of security or twice as many
as we would have otherwise bought but
we're splitting the upside so
essentially we're getting the upside on
the security and we saw in the last
video what the payoff looked like and
let me draw that here so and hopefully
this will be a slightly cleaner version
than I did in the last video so this is
going to be the eventual price of the
security eventual value eventual
security and let me make the y-axis the
eventual value of my investment the
invention value of my investment now if
I just straight-up invested in the thing
then the value of my security is the or
the value of my investment is the value
of the security so it just looks
something like that
looks just like that
so I in my original let's say the value
I if the value of the security ends up
being $30 then the value of my
investment ends up being $30 this is the
scenario where I just straight-up buy
the thing right if the thing ends up
being worth nothing then the value of my
investments nothing if the thing ends up
being worth $60 and the value of my
investment is $60 this is my investment
value not too fancy there but we saw in
the last video as if we do this scenario
where I put 25 50 aside and I only put
for 50
at risk in this type of a reality what
we had is is that if the value of the
security is anything less than 25 50 25
50 then the equity holders here get
wiped out my 450 is worth nothing right
my 450 is worth nothing but I still have
that 25 50 that I've put aside the cash
so my losses were limited to essentially
four dollars and fifty or the capital
that I put at risk so the payoff diagram
then looks like this in an upside
scenario with my 450 investment I'm able
to capture all of the upside that I
would have normally gotten and then my
downside is essentially cap to 450 right
no matter what happens to the security
I'm going to be sitting with 25 50 so
the worst case is that I really just
lose 450 assuming that my original price
that I pay is $30 for the security this
will be my loss and then and this is
obviously my gain just like that
now let's see if we can construct if
there was no Geithner plan let's see if
we could set up the same type of payoff
using I guess more conventional
securities I guess we could call them
and if we can do that then we can try to
price those more conventional securities
and then we have a good sense of the
subsidy or essentially what the
government is giving so instead of the
Geithner plan let's say that we invested
straight up in the security and I'll
just say you know we invest in the
security for $30 and then we also buy an
insurance contract so we so we buy the
security let me buy the security for $30
and then we also buy a put contract or a
put option and that sounds fancy but all
it is it is an insurance contract
essentially on a security so we buy a
put buy a put and the put gives us the
right it's a contract that says that we
can sell we have the right to sell right
to sell our security our security for
2550 and now we don't have to sell our
security for 25 50 let's say it ends up
being worth you know $60 we're out here
then we're just gonna take our put
contract and rip it up it's you know
it's it's worthless we don't want it but
our security we you know with we didn't
need the insurance our house didn't burn
down right but let's say we're down here
that the the the thing we bought this
toxic asset really is worthless then why
we have this contract we got into a
contract with someone else who said that
they would agree to buy that thing for
us from 2550 right we have the right to
sell it to them or to put it to them for
25 50 and this is just so you to get a
little bit of the lingo although you
know many of you all are probably
familiar with this this is the strike
price of the put option and what would
the payoff diagram look like well I have
the security so in all of the scenarios
where the security is worth more than 25
50 right my payoff is going to look like
this it's going to be just along this
line now in these scenarios down here in
these scenarios down here what is what
is my payoff well if my security ends up
if the value of the security ends up
being something less than 25 50 well I
have this thing here saying well you
know the markets saying that they're
only willing to pay I don't know $12
from my security but I have this
contract with somebody that says hey
they're willing to pay 25 50 for my
security so in any of these scenarios
I'm just going to exercise my put option
and I'm just going to sell it to this
guy for 25 50 so no matter in all of
these downside scenarios I still get 25
50 because I have that put option so
essentially as you see this payoff
diagram is identical to what the
government gave us so throughout this
whole you know structure this
public-private partnership all the
government is essentially doing is
giving us a put option with a 25 50
strike price and so to figure out how
large of a subsidy that is we really
just have to figure out what is a put
option with a 25 50 strike price with
and people have one no but it's actually
not that easy to calculate this type of
thing because you have to know about the
volatility of the security and its
dividends and
actually the math to originally come up
with this came out of you know I people
have won Nobel prizes for this but it's
a it's a known problem what I'm gonna do
here and it's it's a little it's a
little bit theoretical what a lot of
people do in reality is they look at
what the market is paying for these
options and then they they figure out
what the implied assumptions are the
volatility and that's really the big
assumption but I just did a little bit
of a web search just to give proper
credit this is math dot Columbia dot
e-d-u
and this is a little what is it a tilde
sign smirnoff slash opsin options
thirteen HTML but what he has here is a
little bit of an options calculator and
I'll take my take my chances with this
guy who's probably a PhD student or
professor at Columbia that he knows how
to calculate options and that his
JavaScript is correct and the numbers
make sense but let's say they say this
is the security in our case is thirty
dollars the strike price is twenty five
fifty they make this larger twenty five
fifty the interest rate so this is the
risk-free interest rate or and it could
also be the interest on the debt depends
but you know it's it's something small
right interest is low right now let's
say two percent the dividend yield this
is I mean we're buying these toxic
assets that essentially have a pretty
high yield and if you're buying it a
thirty cents on the dollar it's probably
you know your yields probably on there
in the range of 30 percent or something
but you can play with these assumptions
I'm trying to be as favorable as
possible to this to kind of see how
large the subsidy could be and what
maybe we'll come up with a range and you
could play with this in your own time
volatility per year I think 30 percent
is pretty fair that in any given year
the perceived value of this could
fluctuate by thirty percent and then
time to expiration these are long-lived
assets a lot of mortgage assets their
average maturities around ten years so
let's instead of 365 days let's make it
ten years three thousand six hundred
fifty days and let's calculate it all
right what we want to worry about is the
American put will in a future videos
I'll talk about the difference between a
European put in an American put but
American put means you can essentially
exercise it at any time you want to
exercise it while a European put just
has an exercise date where that's the
only time where you can exercise your
option but the American put
says that the value of this for the
assumptions we gave is about $19.50 so
it's a pretty big it's a pretty big
subsidy and of course the numbers change
a good bit depending on what you you
know if if we make the yield on the
security less and recalculate it whoops
I made a mistake here it becomes
something less but no matter how you
play with this the assumptions you get
something in the 15 to 20 dollar range
so with that that that uh that option
calculator told us that if you know the
correct price or the theoretical price
for something like this for a put option
for security like this with 30 percent
volatility that maybe has a 30 percent
yield on it because it's paying a lot of
dividends people are paying their
mortgage payments that the option value
of this put if you have to go buy it on
the market you know it's it's arranged
it's maybe 15 15 to 20 dollars so a
rational investor who would have paid 15
to 20 dollars for the option how much
are they willing to pay for the security
plus the option well that same rational
investor we're saying was willing to pay
$30 for the security before and now
they're getting the security and the
option so now they'd be you know if they
had to go buy the option by themselves
they'd have to pay 15 to 20 dollars so
in theory they'd be willing to pay up to
30 plus the value of the option so
they'd be willing to pay you know up up
to I don't know 45 to 50 dollars now I
want to be clear on this if if the
investor with this option is now paying
45 let's say they end up paying 40 let's
say they end up paying $50 right who is
benefitting if the private investor here
ends up paying $50 for the security
because the government is essentially
giving them a free option if they pay
$50 actually paying for what the
government is giving them they're paying
for the option right so the real benefit
is the person selling the toxic assets
which are the you know these banks that
I'd argue are probably insolvent right
so the subsidy wouldn't be to the
private investor it would be to the
banks only if the private investor pays
the same prices that they would have
already paid the $30 and the bank's
willing to sell it for $30 then you
could say that the subs
is going to that private investor but
this begs the whole question the whole
point of this exercise was that you know
the bid in the market right now are what
people are willing to pay is thirty
dollars while the bank's their offer or
what you know essentially they can't
sell for anything less because if they
did then the gig would be up people
would know they're bankrupt the offer is
sixty dollars so even with this this
option that the government is giving
them and even if the if this investor
were to pay up for the entire price of
the option we're kind of getting that
maybe they'll be willing to pay up to
forty five or fifty dollars in which
case the private investor is really
getting no value from this whole gig so
even then you don't get to this point
and obviously if the private investor is
only paying the $30 raise and these
banks this that's no different than what
we're the reality we're already into and
so this goes back to that second the
Gaytan or to video that if even with
this option a rational investor is only
willing to pay up to maybe forty or
fifty dollars how could this plan work
well either won't work because a
rational investor still won't pay kind
of the magic number that the banks need
in order to be solvent or the scenario
that I described in the Geithner plan to
video will happen where the banks have
this huge incentive to buy these for
themselves they just create these kind
of shill hedge funds and you know maybe
I'll do a bunch of videos on all of the
different ways they can do that and
banks are expert at this it's creating
kind of off-balance sheet entities that
they really do control and then those
things participate with the government
and buy the assets off of them so my
general take on it is if when we see
this program start to happen if we see
bids that are above $60 if we see bids
that you know 70 cents on the dollar or
80 cents on the dollar
then these bids are actually coming from
the banks themselves because there's no
rational reason even with the put option
why a regular investor would pay in
excess of 40 or 50 dollars and then
there is a whole liquidity argument here
that Geithner has made that you know oh
well it's not just the subsidy we're
giving it's just also the buying power
that right now you have all these
distressed sellers and you don't have
that many that that many buyers or
dollars that are buying and by kind of
leveraging things up you're increasing
kind of the
buying power out there and in the next
video I'll kind of address that that
question if that is the real problem
that Geithner wants to solve there's a
much better way to solve it than doing
this public-private partnership and
essentially allowing the banks to
potentially set the price
you're either letting the bank set the
price which would be you know a direct
transfer of wealth from taxpayers to
banks that made mistakes or you're
giving a put option which has a pretty
good value to a bunch of hedge funds and
investors who maybe did aren't the
reason why we got into the mess but you
know there's no reason why you should be
transferring money from taxpayers to
hedge funds so in the next video I'll
address that and and but hopefully this
gave you a good sense or of what exactly
the government is doing and how you can
value it see in the next video